if there wasn't a fire up here there it
goes a little bit of onion
sorry about that
welcome to Next Level kitchen where we
are going to give you our tips tricks
and skills to get your cooking to the
next level that's right Gordon and today
we're making one of my favorite meals of
the day breakfast breakfast is essential
that's right we are taking your
breakfast to the next level with some
Mexican inspiration but before we get on
to the breakfast let's talk about
something humble something delicious
that we all use across breakfast yeah
the amazing egg there it is there it is
the egg gotta love them every Chef needs
to know how to cook eggs multiple ways
yes favorite way what would it be oh man
I'd like a nice a nice classic French
omelet to be honest yeah I'm more of a
soft scramble man because that was the
first thing I learned to perfect in
Paris soft scrambled eggs we serve for
breakfast lunch or dinner breakfast will
be done with scrambled eggs lunch wild
mushrooms and for dinner would you
believe uni also I love that I like this
little caviar on top maybe too there you
go yes yes there you go you ready yes
let's go you're familiar with Mexican
Cuisines I am I live in San Diego so I'm
a couple miles away from Mexico
huevos rancheros everyone loves huevos
rancheros what does it mean the food I
like the farm of the ranch you know what
you're going to eat before you have a
lot of work to do during that day it's
basically like your full breakfast
gotcha okay so in England we have a full
English breakfast sausage eggs Tomatoes
beans that pudding white pudding and
toast and fried bread yes and and then
right exactly uh now I'm going to start
off with um some of this beautiful Smoky
chorizo okay I want to get it in there
and get that oil out why the flavor
profile inside there is off the charts
and this will help take any egg dish to
the next level now you can see that oil
literally running out of that sausage
once you've got that going in with your
zucchini or courgette back home bell
pepper
in and now it's all starting to take on
that amazing sausage fridge yeah so
listen you got chorizo I got bacon we're
getting that salty sweet flavor going
and then just right in my cast iron I am
going to cook the bacon and the potatoes
together I have my burrito that I'm
making I'm making a California Burrito
so I got two big flour tortillas that
I'm just gonna griddle and then I'm
gonna make some pico de gallo but I
gotta crack my eggs first are you how
are you gonna how do you crack eggs
Gordon so we will learn carefully to tap
it always on a flat surface yes okay
because that way it stops the shell
going into the egg and sometimes it
breaks the yogurt how are you doing it
oh my gosh I'm not gonna do it that way
I'm gonna just crack it on my bowl and
hope for the best and now all this
pressure's on me so I'm gonna crack
these eggs let's see can I do the two
hand crack can you
believe it or not amazing okay there we
go we got our potatoes cooking we have
our bacon cooking I'm getting going with
our eggs over here and uh yeah we gotta
make some scrambled eggs
I love that I love that now that sausage
has melted the flavor's out so already
the basic veg it starts
to take on a league of its own it's
already going up in the next level
flatten out the ingredients if you plan
out the ingredients like this and
utilize the whole pan what happens is
everything underneath gets really nice
and crispy okay next I've got some
beautiful Chipotle hot sauce it's a
really nice sort of way of just lifting
those vegetables again with a chorizo
and it gets really nice and spicy
now are you doing a quick omelet or are
you doing uh no I'm gonna cook the eggs
in a separate pan I'm just going to
crisp up the potatoes and the bacon over
here and then I like my Scramble to be
nice and fluffy so I'm going to whisk
that get it nice and aerated nice and
fluffy and then I'm gonna cook my eggs
in a separate pan are you using that pan
I was going to use that pan okay I got
one right over here no I got one right
here we're good come on Peaceful beans
uh black beans and that's going to give
you that starch across this amazing
breakfast this is not really a breakfast
for us this is like a sort of brunch
moving into lunch the time I spent down
in Oaxaca honestly this was a staple
almost like a street food breakfast it
was that good think about the layers the
hot sauce the beans and now a little bit
of fresh coriander and then add chopped
tomatoes don't flood it I don't like
this to be too wet in a way that it
becomes too soupy so just three
tablespoons in
now give that a really nice mix up
um tortilla what do you do with that
tortilla okay the tortilla I'm just
gonna throw on my planche I have my eggs
a little bit of brown butter nice and
softly scrambled I'm going to get all
that texture getting from the potatoes
oh sorry you know it's all right you go
first I'll go after you because I have
to make a pico de gallo I need a sauce
for this so pico de gallo or basically a
fresh salsa it's gonna be a chopped up
onion and a chopped up tomato okay there
we go a little bit of chopped onion
right we have our tomato
a little bit of lime here's a little tip
when I cut limes I like to cut them not
in half like you want a lemon but I cut
them in thirds like this because the
cell structure of a lime is a little
different I get more juice out of it
when I cut this lemon into thirds and
this is just going to be the vinaigrette
sort of for my pico de gallo look at all
the juice I get out of the lime right
there
have that got our lime juice onion
Tomatoes our pico de gallo coming
together my eggs are finished where are
we out with the huevos rancheros I'm
getting that I'm getting this again
huevos huevos rancheros love that plus
we'll get my eggs crispy these are not
soft
sort of cooked eggs they're sort of firm
and crispy something quite nice about
that beautiful
crispy Edge again super generous on the
seasoning listen you like spicy food
right I love it okay so I'm gonna use
most of this jalapeno over here not
going to use the seeds
using the seeds makes it a little
spicier love that okay please
are coming along
do you have any chili there I have some
paprika there's a little bit of uh
there's a jalapeno right there if you
want yeah perfect that's good it's a hot
paprika literally go on the top of those
eggs and literally let that sit there
I'm absolutely finish off beautifully by
the way I love this pico de gallo
because people think they have to go out
and they have to buy salsa four
ingredients in a bowl you chop them up
roughly a little bit of lime juice and
we have this beautiful pico de gallo
right here okay my sauce is done my eggs
are done my potatoes are cooking I gotta
get my tortilla just cooked a little bit
here to roll up my burrito so you
mentioned the lime finishing my uh
Farmers eggs huevos rancheros
as well and just to give that little bit
of fragrance in there okay is there is
there anything you can do by the way
honestly this is uh this is one of our
favorites here you know that seriously
fantastic
wow that's good
all right that's very good right
um what's the secret of rolling a gray
burrito wow to me as you want that that
tortilla to be nice and pliable right so
steamed or even if you're home popping
it in the microwave but look I barely
cooked it just a little bit of char
almost just kissing each side of the
Plancha love that so that we just barely
so it's so it's pliable if it gets too
crunchy we can't roll our burrito gotcha
so here we go I'm gonna double double
stack this I'm going big I'm going next
level over here Gordon I'm going to
start adding all my ingredients to my
burrito wrapper I'm dying to see how you
roll this amazing burrito okay I mean
listen we'll see how I can do it I'm
gonna load it up I think the key to a
good California Burrito is to just get
all of the things all of the stuff the
eggs the potato the bacon the chorizo
whatever you're doing getting it in
there I'm gonna add a little bit of my
cheese right on top of the hot eggs yes
because we want that to melt a little
bit of salt and then I'm gonna top it
with some pico de gallo and some
avocados gonna make it nice and Cooling
that look at that fresh flavor in there
let's just see if I can roll this up a
little tip when you're dicing avocado
leave it in the Shelf okay hit it with a
little touch of lime juice okay and then
very carefully get your finger there and
rub that so it stops from oxidizing and
then just crisscross very carefully with
your knife okay one way turn it upside
down and go again and all you're doing
now is sort of dissecting that inside
and I'll show you how we finish our
beautiful Farmer's eggs I love that yeah
I love that's four mistakes way more
rancheras
another little tip for the avocado is
how to get that how do you get the
actual pit out of there gotcha be very
careful but with your chef's knife
you're just going to get in there take
the pit out with your knife there you go
um okay traditionally it'll be finished
with uh
little Cotija which is basically a
salted cheese so so I'm gonna use feta
fat is perfect salted ricotta you know
the thing I love about global Cuisine is
it's on the sit every culture's got a
salty crumbly cheese in this case it's
Cotija or feta if you want Tia thank you
is that thing rollable I don't know I
don't know I'm going big I mean I I
don't think so let's see let's see is it
rollable yeah no you got it Gordon
listen this is like you tucking it in
have you yeah you got to tuck it in you
gotta go with the big you got to get
your hands in there I'm eating this so
don't worry if my hands are on this you
gotta give yourself a fold there you go
you gotta fold it up on the side so you
lose an avocado on the side not a big
deal I love that that's how you do it I
I can't believe you doubted me for a
second look at that okay listen as I say
in Scotland that is well packed
and if you want you can put it on the
Plancha get it nice and crispy but I
think I'm ready to Plate I see you
plating already I'm just starting so
I've sort of crisped up my tortilla I've
got my beautiful veg and tomatoes spicy
tomatoes
now from there as you saw I finished out
a little touch of lime zest I want my
eggs super crispy the beans have been
sort of amazing crisped up so I'm just
gonna
drop them around the outside
and the most important thing here is
that this thing is sort of almost like a
little pick a mix when you dive into
this you quite love it you struggle on
where to start the eggs
beautiful crisp eggs sit on top they're
crispy but they're still runny and
that's the secret okay I told you about
the avocado I've sliced that take a
spoon and look as you go inside all
these little bits of avocado just break
off because you've diced them up and
we're just scooping that out over
your eggs oh fantastic now listen I'm
going to give not that you need it
because you have millions of followers
but a good social media tip is if you
want your burrito to get extra like
scored in I'm going to slice it in half
and then you gotta do the social media
fold where you take the burrito
stack it on top of each other and this
have you noticed that only social media
influences present their burrito like
this look at that it is the shot okay
I'm gonna plate it
now once the avocado is on just get some
of that beautiful feta and just crumple
it and that's going to give you that
nice saltiness over the finish and
honestly
this is a breakfast to die for not only
have we elevated your breakfast to the
next level but trust me that'll keep any
farmer anywhere in the world happy with
a beautiful huevo wow rancheros
[Music]
that looks delicious great job seriously
really good job Indeed now that's how
you take and elevate your dish to the
next level now to get the ingredients
and more details on today's recipes
check out the description below and be
sure to subscribe for more amazing
recipes from this genius and this genius
too well done good job
[Music]